la perturbation
il fallait que je regarde là je comptais
je retape la perturbation qui
intéressait notre région cette nuit se
décale assez rapidement vers le sud-est
et vous qui avez la chance de pouvoir
partir en congés allez bénéficier d'une
tente tout à fait agréable pour votre
week-end en effet de même et ça tombe
vous avez eu peur une première deuxième
à bon d'accord météo une deuxième
la perturbation qui intéressait notre
région cette nuit se décale vers le
sud-est et vous qui avez la chance de
pouvoir partir en congés allez
bénéficier d'une tente tout à fait
agréable c'est bon là oui le son ça va
météo une troisième pour dimanche
et bien le temps sera toujours bon et
bien ensoleillé avec quelques passages
nuageux un peu plus importante en fin
d'après midi